and we've got another Fox News Alert for
you on this busy news day lawyers
representing Trump attorney Michael
Cohen say that stormy Daniels's attorney
Michael avenatti has been spreading
demonstrably false information about
Cohen they say that some of the wire
transfers avenatti highlighted are
allegedly from a different Michael Cohen
he got the wrong Michael Cohen they say
and apparently they're right
still Cohen's lawyers the correct
Michael Cohen's lawyers concede that
some of those records are real and that
avenatti should not have had access to
them his financial information now fair
play as long as it's being used to hurt
a political enemy that appears to be the
new lesson today from Washington store
McDaniels lawyer has confidential bank
statements and so the question is how
did he get them whose custody were they
in we don't know because avenatti won't
reveal that the Treasury Department
inspector general's office has announced
it is launching a probe to find out
Andrew McCarthy is of course a former
assistant US attorney he writes widely
on these subjects and is read avidly by
many and he joins this time this regard
thanks for coming on thanks for having
me it's a narrow question but it's a
meaningful one how do you get a hold of
somebody's bank records I thought
they're supposed to be private
well they're supposed to be private a
lot of stuff that happens in
investigations is supposed to be private
like grand jury material according to
the attorney for Cohen he was given
commitments by government prosecutors
that to the extent they had financial
information of his that would remain
confidential so if the IG from the
Treasury Department is opening an
investigation that's a pretty good sign
that they think it came from the
government well so could the government
leak my medical records or my home
address or the name of my kids school I
mean is there a limit to the private
information that can be leaked if they
don't like you
Tucker they've been leaking classified
national defense information since
before the 2016 election and we had
torrents of it around Trump's election
so the point being if they can leak
things that are important to them
why on earth wouldn't they be able to
leave things that are important to you
well that's a very that's a very smart
point and yet at the same time
paradoxically and you've written about
this they're withholding information
from the public on the grounds that it
might affect or harm American national
security in it starting to seem like
maybe they're withholding information or
to protect themselves things that we
should know about we don't know about
because of see why is it fair yeah I
think it is there I mean you know look
there's probably not one silver bullet
answer to why they they do everything
and I'm certain that there are national
security
I mean look we're talking about FISA
Court proceedings intelligence
information they're gonna be methods and
sources and and stuff that we get from
foreign intelligence services there's no
doubt about it but the thing we have to
be mindful of is every time they've been
pressed when they say national security
or or investigative integrity is the
reason that they have to withhold
something what we find when we finally
peel it back and get to see it is that
they're protecting either their own very
flawed sometimes decision-making
processes embarrassment or exculpatory
information so you really have to be
skeptical when they say we need to hold
this for national security reasons so
I'd be interested in your take on the
Cohen story I mean nothing about Michael
Cohen to be honest would shock me right
but it's hard to assess in the early
hours of a story like this how
significant it is what do you make of
this well I've been the thing I keep
telling myself is that Muller
voluntarily gave this case to a
different prosecutor I can't imagine if
he thought that Cohen was the key to
establishing some kind of connection
between Russia and Trump that he would
ever have let this case walk to a
different prosecutor so what I think is
what I've thought from the beginning
which is it's a Southern District of New
York case my old office here in
Manhattan
they are probably looking at a lot more
than a campaign finance violation but
with Rosen Stein the Deputy Attorney
General having told the president that
he's not a target I think we should
assume until we see otherwise that this
is a case about Cohen
it sure seems like a case about Cohen
right so you're reading all these this
speculation about how Cohen's gonna turn
on the president is that a concern and
if he did what would he say you know I I
always say the same thing would that
question comes up about anybody which is
sure you can pressure mana for it you
can pressure cone you can pressure all
these people but the only time it's
effective to have somebody flip on
somebody else is if they have anything
incriminating on them and if they don't
you know this is why people read you so
avidly
it's wise thank you if any McCarthy I
appreciate it thanks Tucker